مع تزايد الاستخدامات العسكريه للذكاء
الصناعي في مجال الصناعات العسكريه وكذلك
ظهور اسلحه ذاتيه التوجيه تتصاعد المخاوف
على الجانب الاخر من خروج هذه الاله عن
السيطره سواء بفعل قصور تكنولوجي او هجمات
سيبراني لكن السؤال كيف يرى العلماء هذه
المخاوف وكذلك كيف يستعدون للتعامل معها
[تصفيق]
للوقوف اكثر حول تفاصيل التطور الذي تم في
تقنيه الروبوتات حول العالم يشرفنا ان
يكون لنا هذا اللقاء مع البروفيسور اسامه
الخطيب استاذ علوم الحاسب ومدير معهد
الروبوتات في جامعه ستانفورد في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه سر اسامه اهلا بك معنا
في عسكريتها اهلا بك استاذ اسامه يعني
اجمالا في شكل موجز ابرز الانجازات التي
همم حدثت في مجال الروبوتات حتى هذه
اللحظه
عن الروبوتات التي كانت تستخدم في
القطاعات الصناعيه والتصنيع وتدريجيا خرجت
الروبوتات عن هذا الاطار لتدخل فيه عالمنا
الحقيقه وهذا تسبب في تحديات كبيره على
الروبوتاتها وفي نفس الوقت توفر امكانيات
المدهشه لتقديم الروبوتات لمساعده البشري
في منازلهم ونسمي تلك الروبوتات بالمنزليه
ومساعده العمال والتفاعل مع البيئات
المعقده المختلفه مثلا اذا ما اردنا
المشاركه في عمليات خاصه بهزه ارضيه او
اذا تعذر ارسال البشري بشكل امن داخل مبنى
فسنستطيع ان نرسل الروبوتات هناك تطبيقات
عديده فقد بدانا مؤخرا بباذل جهود كبيره
في الروبوتات تحت المياه التي سمحت
باستكشاف عوالم نعرف عنها اقل مما نعرفه
عن القمر او حتى المريخ والمحيطات كما
تعرفون تمثل نحو 70% من كوكبنا ولا يمكن
ان نغتصدون المئه متر تحت مياهها كل ذلك
جلب تكنولوجيا جديده لمساعده البيئه
والعالم وكذلك البشر
[موسيقى]
ولكن يبدو انه لم تعد المجالات الانسانيه
فقط هي التي بها الروبوتس في هذه المرحله
الان الروبوتس اا تدخل بشكل كبير جدا في
التقنيه عالم السلاح انت كمتم بهذا المجال
وبروفسير كبير في هذا المجال هل لديك
تخوفات من دخول الروبوتس في هذا الخط خط
التصنيع الدفاعات العسكريه والله
اوف ربابه
قانون الروبوتات ينص على ان الروبوتات يجب
ان تقدم الخير للبشر وليسائهم وهناك
نقاشات واسعه حول مساله استخدام الروبوتات
لاغراض عسكريه هناك مسائل واخلاقيه عديده
مرتبطه باستخدام الروبوتات وحقيقه ان
الروبوتات بدات تقترب في عملها من البشر
تسبب تحديات عديده كيف يمكن ان يكون هناك
تفاعل امنا بين اله يمكن ان تكون خطيره
وانسان واذا ما حدث خلل في اجهزه السيطره
يمكن ان يؤدي ذلك الى ضرر بالبيئه التي
يعمل فيها الروبوت او حتى اصابته انسان كل
هذه المسائل باتت جزء اساسيا من اسلوب
التفكير الجديد بتطبيقات الروبوتات وهناك
تخوف من الروبوتات يتجاوز بخاوف افلام
الخيال العلمي وهذا يشمل اصول الروبوتات
الى مراحل ذكاء متقدمه تمكنها من
الاستيلاء على وظائفنا وعلى كوكبنا وتتحكم
بكل شيء ولكنني اود ان اطمئنكم بان
الاشخاص الذين يعملون مع الروبوتات
والاجهزه المتقدمه بعيدون جدا عن هذه
القدره واذا ما كان هناك اي شك حول السلوك
الروبوتات فبامكاننا فصلها عن الطاقه
الرساله
او مركبات التنقل فهي تختلف عن الروبوتات
التي نتحدث عنها التي لها اضرار وايد تؤدي
الواجبات والاعمال اما الالات المسلحه فهي
مختلفه وهي موجوده اصلا فاذا ما تاملنا في
الطائرات العسكريه فهي بمثابه الروبوتات
امين
في الشرق الاوسط بروفسل اسامه نحن بعيدين
جدا عن هذا المجال في هذه المرحله يعني
هناك خطوات ولكنها خطوه ما زلت تبدو ضعيفه
في بعض الاحيان وبسيطه في احيان اخرى كيف
تقيم التقدم في مجال الروبوتات في الشرق
الاوسط وما هي ال- ال- الخطوات التي يجب
ان يتم اتخاذتها في الشرق الاوسط وفي دول
الشرق الاوسط حتى يكون هناك صناعه واضحه
وتقدم واضح في هذا المشغل همم
اي اي فرسيسبيتل اند
فيرستوا في اول مؤتمر روبوتات عربي في
عمان بالاردن وسعدت جدا لاطلاق برنامج مثل
هذا الذي جمع ممثلين من العالم العربي
باكمله للمشاركه واذكر محادثاتي مع الطلبه
الذين حضروا الاجتماعات وقلت لهم ان لدينا
عقول نيره في العالم العربي واشخاص مميزين
لديهم امكانيات رائعه لاجراء الابحاث في
مجالات مختلفه من ضمنها الروبوتات ولكن
للاسف ليست لديهم الفرصه للقيام بذلك بسبب
صعوبه الحصول على المختبرات والادوات
والبيئه المطلوبه وانا سعيد جدا لرؤيه ما
يجري في دول الخليج وبعض المؤسسات في
مراكز الابحاث في العالم العربيه حيث
بدانا باجراء الابحاث في تلك المجالات
وعلوم الروبوتات معقده لانها تتطلب
الروبوتات والبنت التحتيه ولكنني اعتقد
حقا ان جيلنا لديه القدرات لتذليل كل هذه
التحديات الخاصه بالابحاث دون اي صعوبه
اذا مات سنه لهم الفرس انا واثق ومتفائل
بالمستقبل سواء امر لك اوفر